uh the you you two remove the dislike
button
people are tight yeah i don't like that
neither
why
honestly i'm just going to say what
shifty posted on instagram say it
shifty said he can't tell if a video is
worth watching like a tutorial
based on their no not being any like
button oh that's true but i'm sure there
should be a ratio of like to views and
now we'll pay attention to that
right
like
it might not be as good but like for
example if the tutorial was really good
it'd have a high view count with a
highlight count if it's got 10 000 likes
you're like oh that's probably good
right but if it's got a million views
and like 30 likes you're like something
is off
yeah it seems like they're trying to
mitigate like people getting ratio ratio
so like you post a video that like is
good but it's about like some like
typically like a liberal take and then
it'll get like 10 000 up votes but then
it'll be like a hundred thousand down
votes so the ratio is crazy even though
your fans actually liked
it i think it's what they're trying to
mitigate so why don't they just reduce
the value of a dislike in the algorithm
but keep it there so people can see
i mean maybe they've already done that
but the video itself you'll look at and
be like wow public opinion must really
hate this video on what's being said
because the ratio is so crazy also
wouldn't it be weird if there's like 100
likes and 99 dislikes and then you press
dislike and it's like 99.25
no no
no you're saying like the weight in the
algorithm yeah wait in the audience not
the actual but you're still gonna look
at the [ __ ]
that was one of the dumbest things i've
ever seen
in my entire life
holy [ __ ] yeah why don't we make the
likes pesos
but you're still going to look at the
[ __ ] no matter what dummy dude no no
you're still going to take your
graveyard
you can get out
you [ __ ] reason really bro
[Laughter]
oh you got out of there you [ __ ]
swerved out of it
uh
conspiracy corner the most disliked
video ever is produced by youtube
youtube rewind 2018. i heard
but also has a ton of likes why did
everybody hate it
because like youtubers like creators are
kind of like uh you guys you could say
purists in a way i don't really like
youtube like making a corny video with
like celebrities that aren't actually
youtubers exactly i think that's really
what it is like
there are youtube celebrities and then
there are celebrities that use youtube
like will smith was big into it etc and
like
having that yearly wrap-up feature all
these celebrities because you know it
looks really cool for the brand etc
probably made these youtube purists go
yo we're the ones that build this [ __ ]
we're getting all the views we're doing
all this work we don't have these crazy
[ __ ] production companies we're doing
ourselves like make it around us i can
understand how they feel away yeah i
can't do it like how do you do that [ __ ]
with the fancy movies yeah you know
i don't like it go why
because our numbers on flagrant have
this unbelievably high proportion of up
likes it down likes
analyze like i'm just saying this
selfishly but like when you look at
trying to tell someone that some of the
takes that you guys make on things are
so wild but you still see how in favor
of those views people are
especially when we're talking to
advertisers and we're like look people
like it it's kind of like one of these
things
watching movie trailers quickly when
it's honest it's it's like what shifty
said
it's a real lead in into the video so
one of the guys that posted the very
first video ever on youtube which was
posted like what was it
13 no like 15 16 years ago a long time
ago it's just this video called me at
the zoo is like one of the first like
creators and like one of the first
employees at youtube
yep he posted in the description
basically saying that the dislike thing
is [ __ ]
so he was like calling the removal of
dislikes a good thing for creators
cannot be done without conflict by
someone holding the title of youtube's
creator liaison we know this because
there exists not a single youtube
creator who thinks that removing
dislikes is a good idea for youtube or
for creators so what do you do to stop
the ratio
these hordes of people that are just
trying to [ __ ] up a video because they
don't like the views of that person or
like that person the same [ __ ] happened
to seth rogen essentially yes what do
you do to stop that
i mean these are smart [ __ ]
right dealing with these sophisticated
algorithms you can't find some way to
like notice if something's being ratio
like come on i can't i can't fathom that
there's no way to crunch all that data
and immediately know that this is a
targeted attack especially if these
people are clicking on the video
disliking it immediately and then just
clicking right out yeah there's got to
be a way based off of their other watch
patterns they'll be like oh yeah
why don't they just give the creator the
option same way like instagram oh yeah
turn on your light count if you want
that's a good idea you can also turn off
like public likes and dislikes i think i
think youtube lets you do that
oh you can i'm pretty sure oh yeah they
let you turn it off
but i think the thought is like
if
they're just trying to mitigate for
people just rationing and i think this
is the best solution they came up with
yeah it's a shitty solution yeah and it
looks [ __ ] it looks like they're trying
to protect people from uh criticism and
brands and [ __ ] that actually give them
big money i'm assuming oh because i
think there'll be brands that'll do like
some woke ad and then they're just gonna
get ripped and then they're like why are
we even using this platform if we're
just gonna get publicly ridiculous uh
all right well they tell those brands to
take off the [ __ ] like dislike